the u.s purchasing 100 million more
doses of the pfizer coronavirus vaccine
effectively doubling the federal
government supply from the company it's
all part
of the trump administration's effort to
inoculate every american
who wants a shot by june with edward
lawrence he's live in washington now
with the latest on this edward yeah
molly this is a classic economic
transaction what can we give you
and what can you do what do you need
from us now the u.s
is paying pfizer 1.95 billion dollars
to get an additional 100 million doses
of the vaccine
and also agreeing to help pfizer get
more raw materials
is the us now pfizer has been limited in
its capacity to make more vaccine
because
it needs more of the stuff used in its
vaccine
well now the u.s will get a total of 200
million doses from pfizer alone under
the agreement
70 million extra doses will be delivered
by july 31st
the remaining 30 million doses after
july 31st
and you know everything has become
political in washington even the vaccine
the pfizer vaccine was given to
leadership on capitol hill for security
reasons
and also alexandria ocasio-cortez and
that has other lawmakers
upset i think the most vulnerable should
get this all along i think we should
have been
protecting the most vulnerable now we
have a way to protect them until
everybody in the nursing home who has
not
got a vaccine gets one until every 80
year old 70 year old six-year-old 50
year old 40 year old gets one
aoc ought to be at the end of the line
waiting her turn because she's at very
very low risk
and this pfizer vaccine was supposed to
be for the most vulnerable and the first
responders
pfizer's perspective the company
delivers the vaccine where the
government tells them
what happens to it after that is up to
those decision makers the bottom line
here
is that operation warp speed has secured
enough of the vaccine for all americans
to have one by june of next year so far
it's been delivered without any issues
that is the pfizer vaccine
and now the moderna vaccine back to you
and for many americans it cannot come
quickly enough edward thank you very
much